[Applaudissements]
une idée par contre avec vous faites
c'est toujours très bon j'ai ça va en
fait bon et beau le monsieur aussi la
demande est beau comment débat où il
fermait les yeux fermés les yeux et
dormait dans cette position maintenant
je vais changer de personnalité
je vais changer sa personnalité l'accord
gilles vous êtes cyril hanouna et vous
vous prenez le contrôle du plateau 1 2 3
vous avez bien vous faire chier
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qui se
passe à telle at war vas-y fais ta
chronique lapenty chronique mais a bien
sûr déjà la chronique
et bien cet aprem je sais pas si ça vous
intéresse ou pas non non non je fais
quoi du coup cette votre unique mais
arrêtez tout c'est comme ça cet après
midi est allé dans les rues de paris
demandent au public ce qu'il pensait de
benjamin voulais qu'on soit pas oui
madame ah oui
benjamin castaldi et benjamin castaldi
aller en ukraine
rudy gay lors il est quoi j'ai pas
d'oreillette quelle heure il est trop
voulait lancer à tort 48 oui on danse on
danse des flux physiques régie comme ça
c'est la merde
américain
la chronique la chronique on est en
retard la chronique ghazi non mais ce
ballon n'est pas vous asseoir
je vais m'asseoir je le laisse aller
alors est ce que vous pouvez dire que
messmer et ton spectacle vous l'avez dit
saubens messmer messmer mais ce père en
spectacle bientôt sur tf1 vendredi soir
rue stark sous hypnose c'est mon
émission préférée
j'adore cette émission franchement même
arthur là dedans je trouve sympathique
c'est une super émission c'est génial
bravo messmer j'adore ce que tu fais
explosivement commissaire
les petits contrer les petits beauté on
y va la vestale dit son livre je n'ai
pas lu mettant son fait
[Applaudissements]
timidement l'ujfp union
il combat il est le con d'al rimal
bombes alliées aux séries ça va oui très
bien ça va très bien fermer les yeux et
maintenant à mon signal de les remonter
aux consciences d'aller vous souvenir de
tout dans les moindres détails et avec
le 1° chez vous avec le 2 le sourire
montre à votre visage
ce bien-être remonte aussi et avec le 3
complètement libérée de toute suggestion
et je pense qu'on a pu applaudir j
aimais no mercy
qu'est-ce que je fais là pris possession
du plateau que j'ai tissé au j'ai été
bon
[Musique]